FENG MIN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the talk.
About the 50 years
ago when I first
left China to come
to the United States
to attend graduate
school at Virginia Tech,
I'm a little bit
excited, but also, it's
a lot of uncertainty.
I wondered if I can adjust
to the culture here.
I worried if my English could
understand by other people
because of my accent.
After I come to the states and
meet all these awesome people,
I find out my experience is
as much as I could imagine.
Likewise, no matter if
this is your first time
on SQL Server or migrating
your existing SQL Server
workload to the Google
Cloud, I hope your experience
will be just as smooth as mine.
Our top enterprise
customers are often
surprised to learn that Google
underlying infrastructure is
the best place to run your
existing enterprise workload.
Windows and the SQL
Server is no exception.
Today, I'll be talking about
run Microsoft SQL Server
on Google Compute Engine.
Just a little bit about
myself00 my name is Feng Min.
I'm the tech leader for the
Windows team at Google Compute
Engine.
My team works on a lot
of different areas--
from the [INAUDIBLE] device
driver to the host hypervisor,
from the BIOS firmware to
the Win32 user end service.
We want to make
sure our customer
to be able to run a SQL server
in the Windows virtual machine
hosted by the Google
Compute Engine.
We want it to be performant,
secure, and reliable.
Here's the rough
agenda for today.
In the beginning, we'll go
over history about the Windows
and the SQL Server on
Google Compute engine.
We will talk about how
to create and configure
a SQL Server instance.
We will go with some
performance improvement,
which is critical for
the SQL Server workload.
After that, my
colleague [INAUDIBLE]
will go on stage
to talk about how
to deploy SQL Server [INAUDIBLE]
group using the power
shell with an interesting
live failover demo.
After demo, we will talk
about storage and back up
and we will share some
tips and the best practice
for the disaster recovery
and also for the performance
tuning.
So our journey for the
windows and SQL server
started a little bit
over two years ago
when we launched Windows
Server 2000R2 support
on Google Compute Engine
in the end of the 2014.
In summer 2015, we announced
general availability
for the Windows Server
on TCE including
the support for the Windows
Server 2008R2 and 2012R2.
Moving into 2016,
we added support
for the SQL server standard
and the SQL server web edition.
Immediately after Microsoft
announced availability
for the Windows server
2016, within a week,
Google Cloud platform
was able to launch
the support for the 2016 on
the Google Compute Engine.
It demonstrated
Google's commitment
for the enterprise customer.
Early this year, we added
support for the SQL Server
Enterprise, including always
on availability group support.
So why do I think it's a good
idea to bring your SQL server
workload to TCE?
First, TCE is a
powerful platform
which has a lot of
advanced feature
which will really power
up your SQL server.
We support VSS
integrated PD snapshot.
You bring the data
consistency of your snapshot
to the application consistent.
Together with the [INAUDIBLE]
SQL server backup support,
it makes it very
powerful to make sure--
take your backup
while the instant is
running without interruption.
We support SQL Server
Enterprise Edition,
which is the always
on classroom support,
allowing you to configure
multiple replicas
for automatic failover
in case of failure.
Google Grid Infrastructure
is the reason
why Google is leading
price to performance.
On the networking side,
Windows VN, VN to VN throughput
can reach up to 16
gigabit per second.
On the storage side, PD SSD
was able to do up to 40k IOPS
all without extra cost.
Second, Google Cloud Platform
and Google Compute Engine
is also a flexible platform.
The permitted billing
gives you fast granularity
to control your costs.
With the [INAUDIBLE]
discount, you
don't have to make
upfront commitment.
No login-- if you keep
using, the discount
will kick in automatically.
The custom machine type
will give the administrators
the full control to specify
the machine with the CPU
and the memory configuration
which match with the enterprise
needs.
We also have a very
flexible license model.
Let's take a look at what
the license model we have.
So we support the
different license models--
bring your own license
or pay as you go.
For the bring your
own license, customers
can choose to bring over their
existing enterprise agreement
with the software assurance
for the SQL Server
and also other Microsoft
Server products like Exchange
Server, Sharepoint Server,
to the GoogleCloud.
The second option is to pay as
you go, only for what you use.
Google provides a
preconfigured image
with SQL Server
preinstalled Together
with the permitted billing and
the assistant user discount,
this makes it a
very flexible option
to control your license cost.
We're talked about a
price already, right?
So we already go with
the permitted billing
and the assistant user discount.
I won't repeat here.
For SQL Server VM Price,
it's considered three parts.
First part is base VM
price, and the other, you
you need to pay the Windows
license cost and also
the SQL Server license cost.
I would like to point out
here for the free trial--
our free trial available
for all the SQL Server
image, including the most
premium SQL Server Enterprise
Edition.
So, how to create
a SQL Server VM--
the way to create
a SQL Server VM
is very similar
to how you create
a regular Windows
virtual machine.
To find out how many
different SQL Server
images we support
on Google Cloud,
here's the key cloud
command you can run.
The trick here-- you need
to specify that your image
project is a Windows SQL cloud.
Alternatively, you can also
go to the Application tab
on the cloud console.
You can find the
order available,
the SQL Server image on the
different Windows version
we support.
If you find a particular
configuration,
you need but not in the
list, please reach out to us.
Performance-- everyone
loves performance, right?
Over the last year we
shipped a dozen feature
across different product areas
to improve the SQL Server
experience on TCE.
Here's a few like a
performance improvement
highlight I'd like to show you.
Having a clock in a computer
system is important.
It'll be even better if
the clock can be accurate
and the cost to access
the clock is low.
It turns out that
it's rather difficult
to implement accurate
and efficient time
in a virtualized environment.
Most of the implementation comes
with some performance cost.
The server application
like SQL Server
do a lot of sampling to
measure the operation latency.
So that's why having an
efficient time implementation
is extremely important for
server workload on a cloud
environment.
[INAUDIBLE] TSC is a
hyper-v environment
which allows the virtual
machine to access clock
with native performance
without any performance loss.
You can also help bring
to keep the clock accurate
even where you might create a
machine among different hosts.
To support these
feature in cloud moment
is much more
difficult to support
this [INAUDIBLE] environment.
We are very proud to be the
first cloud provider to be
able to support this feature.
In our internal testing, where
we ran the TPCC benchmark--
of course, you do a lot of,
like, tunnel excess, right?
We are seeing the CPU usage
can job up to 20% to 30%.
All this preciosu
CPU cycle could
be used to do
something more useful
rather than waste on
accessing the timer.
We also made our storage
stack and the network
stack more efficient.
I already talked about the
narrow throughput, the PD SSD.
But also SCSI Multi-Queue
is another feature
which is super useful
for our local SSD
offering on the Windows.
It made our virtual storage
adapter more efficient,
with lower latency
and higher throughput.
Since we [INAUDIBLE] the
SQL Server Standard Edition
like last year, a top
question from the customer
is when Google will start
to support the SQL Server
enterprise with always
on classroom support.
So here we are.
Mission critical
SQL server workload
requires higher visibility
and disaster recovery.
To achieve this,
Google Cloud Platform
supports Windows server
failover cluster.
and always on
availability group.
Always on availability
great group
is the SQL Server
flagship HADR solution
allowing you to configure
multiple replica
for automatic failover
in case of failure.
This replica can be
configured as readable,
allowing you to offload the
read workload and the backup.
So look at the list
reference architecture.
You needed two custom
subnetworks here.
Each custom subnetwork will
host one SQL Server instance.
The main controller on top
can be the same or different
than the subnetwork.
Doesn't matter.
You will also need
Active Directory
as with most typical
windows workload.
And we also promote these domain
controllers to the DNS server.
For both SQL instance, we need
to join with Active Directory
and also update the DNS
setting to use the DNS server.
That's important but the default
GCE DNS will not work here.
In order to specify the
cluster IP and the listen IP
when you're building
out your cluster,
we need to switch from
the DCHP to the static IP
and also config the IP
address using the TCP advance
[INAUDIBLE] so that
the packet can be
forwarded to the correct node.
So in this reference
architecture on the last slide,
I talk about a lot like
how, how you do that.
So now I want to talk
a little bit of why,
why you want to do that.
What's the reason behind that?
First, I would like to point
out that the slide I just
showed you is like an original
[INAUDIBLE] configuration.
However, you can configure
two subnets in the [INAUDIBLE]
or even configure two different
subnet across different regions
to make this a cross region
[INAUDIBLE] configuration.
Of course, if it
is cross region,
you may want to configure
your SQL application
using asynchronous syncrhonous
replication instead
of synchronous replication to
mitigate the latency issue.
Second, the whole
solution was building
on top of a multi-site
failover cluster.
Because it's multi-site,
that's the reason
we need two or more
custom subnetworks here.
It also means the
SQL client needs
to support something called the
multi-subnet failover option
in the connection string.
So when you build
your operation,
you specify the connection
string to connect to SQL Server
Database, right?
That's the option
you need to specify.
It means when you
[INAUDIBLE], usually you
need to run like an
ADO 4.5 or newer.
Because this is billed
as like a faster failover
time, in our internal
testing, we usually
can be finishing
this whole failover
in the 10 to 15 seconds.
Let's talk a little
bit about IP address.
Cloud network usually
is very different
from a traditional on
prem network we've seen.
On a high level, TCE networking
is a big Layer 3 switch.
The usual features
like DHCP broadcast up
does not really
work the same way
as you expected in the
traditional network.
The GCE network doesn't
know about the IP address,
the virtual IP you
config-- like a listen IP,
cluster IP you configure
in the cluster.
So we are not automatically
sign this IP address to your VM.
That's why we need to switch
from DHCP to static IP
and also use routing
to configure this IP
address so the packet
can be forwarded
to the correct secure instance.
As we configure
SQL server, the TCE
advanced routing for the
cluster IP and the listen IP,
by the TCE routing
definition, the IP address
has to be outside of the varied
TCP subnetwork address range
because this user
defined routing is--
if it's inside the
range, the routings
are already pretty fine.
But however, from a
guest perspective,
this list IP has to
be in the same subnet
as the primary internal
IP from VM perspective.
I know there's a little
bit of confusion.
Let's see an example.
So here's a typical network
configuration we use.
We have two subnetworks here--
10.1.1.0 and the 10.2.1.0.
They are both /24 networks.
That's how you create your
GCE custom subnetwork.
On the VM side, you
can that for both VM,
we have a subnet
mask as 255.255.0.0.
So they are both
/16 subnetworks,
which is also a superset
of the GCE subnetwork view.
When we pick up a
listen IP, we just
pick up an IP address
which is outside of the GCE
subnetwork [INAUDIBLE] but
inside the VN subnetwork mask
view.
Take IP1.
I list IP1 as an example, right?
10.1.2.4, which is
outside of subnet 1.
10.1.1.0/24 is outside.
But it is inside of
the subnet mask as
defined by 255.255.0.0,
which is the same network
as the internal IP.
The same is also true
for the listen IP2.
So I want you
understand this picture.
So let's how you pick up a
correct listen IP and a cluster
IP to configure your
always on cluster.
For a customer to bring their
own license to the Google
Cloud, there's extra
work they need to follow.
To get always
network [INAUDIBLE]
I just talking about, they need
to mark their customer image
as multi-IP capable.
To do that, you first
create a disk using
a preconfigured Google image.
Then you create a new custom
image using the command here.
Specify the new flag,
just OS feature flag
called the multi-IP subnet.
Once this is enabled, you'll
get all the network features
I'm talking about in
the previous slide.
For the pre-configured
image released
by Google using the pay
as you good license,
all this has been
automatically taken care of.
You don't need to
worry about this.
So I just talked a lot about the
[INAUDIBLE] group on the GCE.
The manual deploy
needs a lot of steps.
It's very complicated,
to be honest.
With that, let me hand over
to my colleague [INAUDIBLE].
He will talk how to deploy
the always on availability
group using PowerShell
efficiently.
And then he will
also show us a demo
to use in availability
group to handle the failure.
ANIBAL SANTIAGO:
Thank you, Feng.
So my name is Anibal Santiago.
I'm a database
engineer with Google.
I've been working with SQL
multi-IP for at least--
[INAUDIBLE] more than 20 years.
I actually started when it
was called Sybase SQL Server.
And I"m also a Microsoft
certified solutions associate
in SQL Server 2012 and 2014.
So with the Google
Cloud SDK, you
have access to the
PowerShell commandlets
that let you manage your
Google Cloud environment.
We created a SQL Server
high availability
cluster using PowerShell
and that's the one
I'll be demonstrating to you.
The code that we use to create
this cluster is in GitHub.
So you will be able just to
go to GitHub, see the code,
download it, and even modify
it to match your needs.
After that, I will do a second
demo of a Cloud Launcher
template that will
do the same thing.
It will create a higher
availability cluster for you.
This one is useful when you want
to do like a quick tour of SQL
Server HA because
you pretty much
just click and the
whole environment will
be created for you.
So let's go to the demo.
So first, I wanted
to just quickly show.
This is the location--
and you will see
the link later on--
where the code that I'll
be showing you precise.
But even before I go
to the actual code,
let me just show
you a little bit how
if you are using the
Google cloud console
how things will look like.
This is after running it.
In this case, we have to note
cluster SQL1, cluster SQL2,
and a domain called DC windows.
One thing I just wanted
to kind of emphasize
is, like, things to be aware.
Like when you set
up your firewall,
notice how I created
three firewalls.
And those firewalls I did
have to create it myself.
There's what one that I call
allow internal ports that just
pretty much allow all traffic
between the three nodes.
I created one called allow RDP.
It's specifically we
want to open port 3389.
Now, this one, I
reopen it to the world.
In your case, you
don't need to do that.
But for simplicity,
I'm just saying anyone
from the world can
really try to do on RDP.
But just be aware of that.
The other thing that
we're going to need
when we do our
PowerShell deployment
is open port 5986 because
we will be using WinRM
to connect to those instances.
So we also need
to open that port.
So beside those three firewalls,
let me just talk a little bit
about four routs.
Later on, I know that Feng
talk about this concept,
but we will need to
create routes in GCP
for the virtual IPs or
for the Windows failover
cluster and the SQL Server
listener, availability group
listener.
So these are the four
routers we also create.
In general, I just wanted
to mention those two things
because those are
the things that you
will have to set up once
you get everything running
if you're doing it manually.
Because I'll show you
the Powershell screen
will do that all for you.
So let me just-- let's take
a quick look at the code.
Actually, I'm going to
minimize this just now.
So just a big summary
about the code--
we split the logic into
three discrete files.
Ideally, you only
need to run one,
but we figure that it's easier
to understand just by splitting
the logic into three files.
The first file that we
call parameters config,
you just enter anything that is
related to your environment--
the name of your node,
the IPs, the [INAUDIBLE]
of your network.
There's a space in that we
specify the name of your domain
and all of that
kind of information.
So this is the place
where you will customize
for this installation.
The other script
is the main one.
And this is the one that
you will always run.
This is the one that we
call Create SQL Instance
Availability Groups.
On the top of the file, we
put a lot of information just
to kind of--
I just want to maximize this
and make it easier to read.
So just to show you
a little bit more,
like give an idea
of what it does.
Now I'm not going to read each
and every line of the code,
but still, I'm just
going to give you
the highlights of what it does.
You will notice how
everywhere we're
using those commandlets
that unless you
are familiar with the Google
Cloud SDK for PowerShell,
you know those are
some of the commands
that you get once you
install the Google Cloud SDK.
So we go through the
process of first deleting
the instance exist.
We will then create both
disks for our two instances.
But again, you know,
there's different samples
of how to use the
Google Cloud SDK.
We go out.
We then will create
the instances.
Now every you create a
Window instance or actually
any instance in
Google Cloud, they
are not available immediately.
You usually have to wait a few
minutes for them to be ready.
So this part of the
code just does that.
It will wait until the
instance are ready.
Once they are ready, we need
to generate a password in order
to be able to log
onto the server.
So in this session, we
just generate a password.
Now this is a section
where we create those four
routes that I taught you about
and that we mentioned earlier.
So we create the route for the
virtual IPs for the cluster
and the listener.
And then we start to
pretty much connect.
We put the message here
just to make sure that--
very important that you
have port 5986 open.
And usually if you don't, this
is the part where it will fail.
So one of the
first steps that we
do when we log
onto the server, we
change the network
IP to be static.
So what we're doing here--
just changing the
network IP to be static.
One thing that
happens at the moment
that you change the
network IP to be static,
you lose your connection.
So just to make it cleaner,
we removed those session
variables, connection variables,
and we will recreate them.
And back again we try to
connect to the server.
At this point on, it's just
doing all the other stuff
that you need to do when
setting up SQL Server.
We create folders,
directories where we're
going to start the database.
We open the firewall.
This is the Windows Firewall--
port 1522 for availability
group, port 1433 for SQL
server.
We enable the clustering
feature of Windows
since we are going
to need it later on.
And finally, we add the
computers to the domain.
Once the computers are
added to the domain,
the server will restart.
And that happens automatically.
And pretty much what
they're added to the domain,
we are ready to start
creating the cluster.
So once again,
this session, we're
just waiting for the
computers to restart.
But once they do, we
just bring the message
that says we are ready to
create the windows availability
cluster.
At that moment, we are going
to try to create the Windows
failover cluster.
This is the point where we
decided to put the logic still
in the serve file, which
is the serve file that I'm
going to show in a moment.
It's called
createavailabilitygroup.ps1.
Why did we put that one
still in a different file?
If you're bringing
in your own license,
you will not have SQL
Server preinstalled.
You have to install it yourself.
So what the code will do at
this moment, it will tell you.
It will check to see
SQL Server is installed.
If it's not, it will tell you
please install SQL Server.
And then it will tell
you run this other script
after you're done.
But if you are just bringing--
I mean, if you are just
using the pay as you go,
you know, the whole thing
will continue automatically.
Now, a little bit thing about
this other one, the script that
creates the SQL Server
availability group, this script
has no commands related
to Google Cloud.
So this is just
a script that you
can use to install and set up a
SQL server availability group.
So let's say that on your own
environment, talking about
on premise, if you want to start
up a SQL Server availability
group, you can just take
this section of the code
and just really use it.
So this one has nothing to
do per se with Google Cloud.
So let's go to a
little bit demo and we
are going to test
a planned failover
and an unplanned failover.
Before doing that, I
just want to show you
what is the code I'm using
to test that failover.
So I just rolled like a very
simple PowerShell script
that you have the function
that runs a query.
So it will run any
query that I pass.
Below, the query that I'm
just passing to that function
is I'm adding a
record into a table.
Immediately after,
I'm just counting
how many records the table has.
And when I return, I'm
returning how many records
the table has and also
the name of the server.
The only reason why I've
written the name of the server
is because I want to show you
how the server name changes
when we do the failover.
And I will also,
and you will see it
in a different color,
how many seconds it
took to do the failover.
So in this blue
window is where you'll
find that little piece of code.
So I'm just going to start it.
On the left, it tells you
kind of how many records
are in that table.
Right now, we are
connected to cluster SQL2.
So there are multiple
ways to do a failover.
I'm going to use
PowerShell but know
that you can do that from
SQL Server Management Studio
as well.
But this is the command to
change it to cluster SQL1.
And you will notice here.
So let's run it.
So let's see how long it
takes to do the switch.
What you will expect
in the blue window
is the name cluster SQL1
after doing the failover.
So we get the error
and it took 10 seconds.
And we are back now
running in cluster SQL1.
So this is like
testing how you would
do like a planned failover.
So now let's plan to do
like an unplanned failover.
What I'm going to
do for this one,
I'm just going to restart
cluster SQL1 since that's
a currently active node.
So I already have
the command here.
So I'll just do a full
restart of the server.
What I will expect
after we do this restart
is that cluster SQL2 will
become the one active.
And if I'm able to
enter the Enter--
so minimize that while
And in this case,
you see it took five
seconds to do the switch.
In this case, you will
not see the error.
The query is slipping
every one second.
So it looks like the whole
thing happens within that time.
And at the end that's really the
only thing that pretty much we
test when doing with
failover, it is like,
does it work or does
it doesn't work?
So let me go now and
talk a little bit more
about the other demo
that I said we would do,
which is the Cloud
Launcher template.
So from the Google console, you
can launch this Cloud Launcher.
And in here--
I mean, there is a long list.
So I do suggest
you just touch SQL,
and you will find quickly
the one for SQL Server, which
is this first one.
It gives you some information,
so we'll continue.
Now for the deployment name,
you can choose the name
that it gave you or you
can just type any name.
You have the option to
choose the [INAUDIBLE].
You would need to
specify a domain.
That is the only--
if you want to do it quickly,
that is the only thing
that you only have to enter.
So in this case,
I'm going to say,
create a domain
called dveng.com.
Below, you will see how
you configure your domain
controller.
In this case, I'm
just choosing one CPU.
The Windows version
I'm going to use
is going to be
Windows Server 2016.
Now, the template only supports
for now with the server 2016.
We're planning to
add more versions.
Then you can choose type
of disc, how big the disc.
Then it's a configuration
for SQL Server.
You can choose between two
or three SQL Server nodes.
Same thing-- how many CPUs.
Also, we only support SQL Server
2016 on Windows Server 2016,
but we are planning
to add the others.
The option if you just want to
open the firewall to the public
and click deploy.
Once you click deploy,
it will take 30 minutes.
But pretty much
after 30 minutes,
you will have a working SQL
Server high availability
cluster for you to test.
With that, I will just
switch back again to Feng
to continue with
the presentation.
FENG MIN: Thank you,
Anibal, for the demo.
Now let's talk about the backup
and the disaster recovery.
There's a lot of different
options we can choose here.
First one you can continue
to use building the SQL
Server back up recoverability.
You can use the SQL Server
manual studio, [INAUDIBLE]
or PowerShell commandlet
to do the backup.
Second you can leverage
always on availability group
to have multiple replicas
ideally across different zones
or even different regions.
If one zone fails, the
service can just automatically
failover to a different zone.
Log shipping is an option.
The last option I want to point
out here is you can use PD--
persisent disk--
snapshot integrated with
the Windows Volume Shadow
Copy service.
It will back up your database
with application consistent
and make sure your services keep
running with out interrupted.
If you want to know more
about disaster recovery,
I want to point you to
the white paper here.
It's written by our
famous SQL Server expert
in [INAUDIBLE] in this
SQL Server community
and [INAUDIBLE] is also here.
You're welcome to talk
with him at the talk.
This white paper discussed
the disaster recovery
for the SQL server on
TCE in great detail.
I mentioned multiple [INAUDIBLE]
PD Snapshot with the VSS
integration is something very
powerful and useful for running
your SQL Server
on Google engine.
So why is that?
So what's VSS?
VSS Is technology included
in Microsoft Windows which
allows you take a manual or
automatic backup for the volume
even when they're in use.
Result of VSS integration,
the persistent disk snapshot
is not aware of any
[INAUDIBLE] state.
It's called crash consistent.
For running system,
it's just like you
pulled the cable from the wall.
Whatever is left on the
disk is your snapshot.
That's why on the windows,
the often suggestion
to do a snapshot is
turn off your instance
before you take a snapshot.
This is less than ideal.
For a typical operation,
the VSS requester
here will send a request
to the VSS service.
And the VSS service
will send a notification
to all the VSS writers
[INAUDIBLE] in the system,
including the SQL Server
VSS's writer to tell you, hey,
I'm going to take a snapshot.
Please get yourself ready.
So all the VSS writer,
we are starting--
like, a SQL Server
VSS writer, we
are starting to coordinate
its internal state.
For example, you need to
flush the internal cache
to get itself into a
self-consistent state.
After everybody replied yes
to the VSS service, VSS--
no, everybody is ready.
So he will float
in the I/O and then
send the request to
the VSS writer saying
please take a snapshot.
The workflow showed us that's
why we can take an application
consistent snapshot because
the storage system is
working with the
application like SQL Server
to do the backup.
By integrating PD snapshot
with the Windows VSS,
you combine the benefit
of super PD snapshot
with the consistency
guarantee from the VSS.
You get all this without
affecting your running
instance.
It's the ideal tool to
do the SQL Server backup.
Let me talk about
a little bit more
for the other internal component
involved with the PD VSS stuff.
Internally, we have a
Google VSS agent running
and we also have a
Google VSS provider
in every Windows VM instance
in the Google Compute Engine.
On the back end, when a
persistent disks receives
a request to take a snapshot,
[INAUDIBLE] the hypervisor
will use an extended [INAUDIBLE]
protocol to send the signal
to the guest video driver.
The video driver will
wake up the VSS agent.
VSS agent now acts just
like the requester.
He will notify the
VSS service to say
I want to take a snapshot.
Once VSS service
gets the confirmation
from all the writer,
including SQL server,
then VSS service will notify
our Google VSS provider
saying, please take a snapshot.
Our provider here will
not take a snapshot.
Instead, he will just
sent a notification
to the VSS driver,
the SCSI driver,
and also back end PD service
saying from this perspective,
we are ready.
We already called it
our internal state.
We are self-consistent.
So you can go ahead
with your snapshot.
This is an overly simplified,
high level overview
for how the workflow
working together,
but you should be
get a good idea how
everything works together to
do a VSS enabled a snapshot.
Well, the internal logic
is quite complicated
to actually implement the
PD VSS [INAUDIBLE] snapshot.
To use that, to take a
VSS enabled snapshot,
it's actually very easy.
We add a new parameter in
the existing disc snapshot
API called a [INAUDIBLE] flash.
Depends on this parameter
is true or false,
a PD snapshot
workflow will decide
whether or not to involve
all these guest components
to finish the snapshot.
By default, these
flag, this flash flag,
is false unless you
specify it explicitly.
As with any other GCP feature,
you have redefined the way
to use this feature.
You can use the
API directory, you
can use GCloud
command line, and then
you can also use cloud console.
As always, performance
tuning is always
an important part of the
topic for the SQL Server.
After all, it's still
SQL Server no matter
if it's GCE or not GCE.
So all your existing
knowledge for the performance
tuning for the SQL
Server, most of that
is still applicable here.
I want to point out to
some difference on the GCE.
First, there's a
different storage option
on GCE-- local
SSD versus PD SSD.
So which storage
option should I use?
Local SSD is faster, much
faster than the PD SSD,
but it's not as
durable as PD SSD.
In general, for those
database workload,
we suggest you go
with the PD SSD.
If you want to go
with local SD, you
need to configure using
always on [INAUDIBLE] group,
configure multiple replicas to
just prepare for the failure.
However, local SD is very useful
to put up your performance.
A couple of scenario here--
the first scenario here, you
can use local SSD to hold
onto your Windows page
file to speed up the page
for the handling for Windows.
And then you can also
use the local SSD
to hold the temp DB file.
Generally speaking,
it's a good idea
to have-- you have a dedicated
disk to host all your database.
So when you format your
disk, format the file system
on the disk, we suggest you to
set the allocation unit size
as 32K because this will work
best with the underlying PD
infrastructure.
On the on-prem
environment, usually we
heard the suggestion.
I get, hey, keep your
data file and the log
file separate on different disks
for the isolated performance.
But however, on
cloud environment,
the persistent disk is
already distributed disk.
[INAUDIBLE] back
up a lot of disk
on the machine on the back.
So keep the data in the
log in the same large PD.
We will not lose any
performance and you'll
make your life a lot
easier when you deal
with the things like backup.
Again, this is a very
high level summary.
You were interested, you
can go to the [INAUDIBLE]
here for the past
practice recommended
for the Google Compute Engine.
To summarize, today, we go
over the basic SQL Server stuff
on Google Compute Engine.
We had a deep dive on the
always on availability
group with all the
technology behind the scenes.
We reviewed the storage and the
disaster recovery operation,
including how to use
VSS enabled PD snapshot.
I hope you find that the
information here is useful.
Here's additional
information you
can follow if you're interested
to how to run the SQL
Server on Windows.
I want to highlight the three
white papers here written
by Brett [INAUDIBLE].
This is a very detailed,
comprehensive guide
to how to use the SQL Server on
Google Compute Engine-- highly
recommended.
There's another talk
on the conference.
Unfortunately, some talks
conflict with this talk.
If you're interested to learn
the Windows workload on Google
Compute Engine, I recommend
you go to tomorrow
at the same time, the
IO220, "Deploy Windows-based
infrastructure on the
Google Compute Engine."